the first thing i'd say is about sarah
everard's family and friends who are
going through
unspeakable grief many many women last
night wanted to come together
to mark that grief but also to share and
shine a torch on a wider experience of
women about the fear
uh the threats and the violence and
abuse that they face on a daily basis
they were right to do that
they should have been allowed to protest
to have their vigil to come together
in peace and i was very disturbed to see
the police action
i think it was wrong and i'm pleased
it's now going to be
reviewed
i don't think president should resign we
need to see the
reports that have now been called for
but more than that this is a bigger
issue
all of the concerns all of the problems
with violence against women girls have
been there for a very very long time
this week in parliament we start a
policing bill
300 or so pages 170 something clauses
and almost nothing almost nothing if you
can believe it
on violence against women and girls the
gaping hole in this bill is why we'll be
voting against it
and a complete missed opportunity by the
government up until this afternoon
labour mps were tweeting that they were
being told to abstain rather than vote
against
why has that changed i've been talking
to the front bench team for several days
and we made a decision
this morning and i can tell you why we
made that decision because this bill
was the chance to deal with all of the
underlying issues with violence against
women and girls
they've been there for years and years
and years this government's been in
power
for 10 years and it's now brought
forward a policing bill
300 pages 176 clauses
and almost nothing on violence against
women and girls lots of stuff on
statutes
nothing on statues nothing of any
substance on violence against women
and girls i think a lot of people will
say there's a missed opportunity
gaping hole and that's why i'll be
voting against it you're voting against
it but what do you propose to do
to bring in those measures you're
talking about well we've been pushing
those measures in other legislation
if the government if the government
wants to take this moment
to pause to step back and to
reach a consensus across the house on
the measures needed to tackle violence
against women and girls
then bring it on we will work with them
on that but they need
to bring forward a piece of legislation
now with
next to nothing on this crucial issue
for all the people
that were out last night peacefully
demonstrating trying to bring to the
attention
of politicians and others the daily
harassment and abuse
all of those uh require us to listen to
them and to bring forward legislation
that actually addresses
the long-term problems we've had with
violence against women and girls
in a way this is a systematic
long-standing problem what
specific steps what specific measures
could be introduced that would achieve
what you want
i'm sick of people saying this is a
long-term problem
we know what the issues are um
many women in particular feel they can't
come forward to report what has happened
to them we need to address that put the
support
in places that be report left right and
centre on that they need support
to survive through the court process
many women won't come forward
if they do come forward uh the the
ordeal as it often is of going to court
is too much
for many of them the sentencing needs to
be adjusted stalking needs to be
addressed
in particular we could fill a 300-page
bill
with provisions to better deal with
violence against women and girls and
frankly that's what this bill ought to
do
on a different topic nazanin zadari
ratcliff is on trial
again what does the british government
need to be doing
well the government needs to do
everything it can to
ensure that she is released she's been
through um an awful awful ordeal um
and all of us uh want to see her
released
um and i want the government to do
everything within its power to ensure
that she is
are there any specific steps that they
need to take in your eyes well there are
lots of steps that um they need
to take but they are working on this um
this is a non-party political issue i
think all of us just want to see that
release
as soon as humanly possible
what did you get and how are you feeling
astrazeneca i feel great and i'm really
grateful
not only to the front line team here at
the crick institute who've been
absolutely brilliant
but to all of those on the front line
across the country are doing a fantastic
job in rolling out the vaccine so
from me not just on my behalf but on
behalf of everybody else a massive thank
you